dr phone france uh can you
explain the concept of the
personal shadow and the collective
shadow
well the in practical life they emerge
but the personal shadow is the personal
shortcomings of
things which every human being could be
conscious of which is not archetypal
and therefore not a mystery for instance
such things as
greed for money or jealousy
dallas is one of the main aspects of the
shadow
or laziness sloppiness
unrelatedness sentimentality and whatnot
inferiorities which everybody has
but prefers not to know about
and because we generally strive through
education and through environmental
pressure to be a bit better than we
actually are
or we have our own ideals i opened to be
jealous i opened to have a power complex
and but you see for instance that in
criminals
they sometimes leave their inferiority
and then they have a personal shadow
which is noble
they dream about noble people and
it's just reversed they live so to speak
their mean side
and and then they have a a positive
shadow
and therefore even in uh what is more
the average truth
the inferior shadow is not really bad
it's just human all too human
and something one could know about if
one is jealous or if one is suddenly
possessed by wanting money
or so on one one could know about it if
one is honest with oneself
but the collective shadow has to do with
the dark side of the archetype of the
self
that means is the shadow of the god
image
in the christian tradition it would be
the devil
and that has always been personified and
felt as something
which has not to do with directly with
the human being i mean if somebody is
possessed by the devil he's much
worse than just he's not human
it's demonic and
but on the other hand generally that
merges first you have this
area of dim dark side
and behind it lurks the other i for
instance seen that when
germany went to the devil in nazism
people fell into it through their
personal shadow
for instance they didn't want to lose
their job because they
were clinging to money that was their
personal shadow but then they joined in
with the nazi movement for that reason
and did much worse things than they
would have done
normally under normal social conditions
so you can say the personal shadow is
the bridge to the collective shadow or
the open door to the collective shadow
but the collective shadow comes up in
those terrible
mass psychosis well now if a person
becomes more aware
of any personal change that's why it's
so
tremendously important because then you
don't fall into the collective shadow
there's not that um automatically it's
not that
it's like if you have a room and there's
one donor trap
and the other devil can come in and if
you know your personal shadow you can
shut all the doors
so first and then you don't join in into
massacres
and holocausts and such
you catch yourself and you catch
yourself and you realize
and you can keep out of it and keep
reasonable
keep your head while the average person
who has doesn't know about
her personal shadow they get swept away
by the collective evil
is it possible to speak of a shadow in
terms of national identities a shadow in
switzerland a shadow in the united
states
yes naturally the summing up of
every society has its ideals and lives
up to those ideals
and has also a shadow the average
american
has a typical shadow and the average
swiss has a typical shadow which is
slightly different
[Music]
but there again you can say the more
individuals in the nation know about
their shadow
the better that nation is all of or less
likely to fall into a mass psychotic
destructive
sweeping away movement where people lose
every measure you know i mean just
kill their relatives kill thousands of
people without even
having a bad conscience about it this
just madness